[Music]
everybody is Charlie there's a whole
bunch of surprises that we found in
alternate versions of the Avengers end
game trailer so I'll break it down there
was also a big spread where Kevin Feige
the Russos and the writers revealed a
bunch of details about the characters
and you'll also notice that some of the
trailer scenes that we saw showed up in
featurettes that they released for
Avengers infinity Wars so I'll point out
some of the corresponding shots because
there's one very notable actor that we
know died during infinity war that's
showing up at these locations in
Avengers endgame if you're new to my
channel I do Marvel Easter Egg videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything I also do weekly giveaways
I'll explain at the end of the video so
I just broke this down top-10 style
starting with number 10 the Disney Fox
Deal is actually done today they just
finished buying all their outstanding
shares I believe the transaction
completes at midnight tonight but that's
how they bought them they buy all the
shares of their company so as of
midnight tonight Kevin Feige can
actually call up filmmakers and start
talking about making Fantastic Four
x-men
Deadpool movies this is also connected
to some of the other things on my list
here so I'll just address this as we go
along 9 Joe Russo recently just took his
daughters to the Captain Marvel premiere
no big surprise there while he was
walking the red carpet of course
interviewers were asking him questions
about Avengers endgame trying to get
details out of him he said his daughter
plays a secret character during avengers
endgame but wouldn't say who that
character was well look at this hawkeye
pre-snap
moment on his farm teaching his daughter
how to shoot a bow and arrow and who
does Hawkeye's daughter look like looks
amazingly like Joe Russo's daughter so
it seems like she's just playing a
slightly older version of Hawkeye's
daughter than we saw during Avengers age
of Ultron
because remember during the events of
ant-man and the wasp ant-man had the
ankle bracelet that they had to take off
because of the deal he cut after Captain
America Civil War Hawkeye did the same
thing he spent all that time with his
family so he would have been with his
family with his ankle bracelet on when
the snap went down so they're legit
might be a moment during avengers
endgame where they make you watch
hawkeye watch his family turned to dust
that's gonna be pretty horrific number 8
if you look at a slightly different
version of the trailer that they posted
to Instagram you get a little more
footage top to bottom in the frame you
can see that ant-man is lugging Hank
pins tiny lab with the luggage handle
and the
wheels rolling his way down the sidewalk
freaking out about all the missing
persons posters and strange lack of
people post snap we could talk for an
hour about what they're gonna do with
that lab but I think it's pretty obvious
is that he's gonna take it to the
Avengers base eventually when he wheels
up in his van and he's gonna give it to
them eventually they'll use the lab to
figure out how to use quantum energy and
make these suits that would also pay off
an Easter Egg from way back in the first
ant-man film when Hank Pym says I'll be
damned if I let a stark get his hands on
my technology
only instead of Howard Stark getting his
technology it's gonna be Tony Stark
seven later in the trailer you can see
Captain America when they're all doing
their slo-mo hero walk moment in the new
quantum suits he's carrying his shield
but because it's turned away in the
frame is really dark you can't really
tell if it's any different from the
original shield which I believe that
he's using when he's in his scale armor
here when they're probably fighting
Thanos earlier in the film there's still
the spider-man homecoming Easter egg
caps new prototype shield that they may
pay off during the movie the only way
that they accomplish something like that
where he has two different shields
during the movie would be is if they
lose to Thanos early in the movie when
they try to fight him with a smaller
squad Stannis breaks his vibranium
shield so that Iron Man has to finish
that new prototype shield for later in
the film but that's just speculation
number six this is a big one where you
see Hawkeye at this cabin talking to
Captain America is out near the woods by
a lake they're talking to each other as
probably after black widows gone to pick
Hawkeye Ronan up from Japan where he's
been this place here this whole cabin
appears during the special feature at
the Kevin Feige and Joe Russo released
last year you even see Chris Pratt's
star-lord looking like he's dressed down
getting ready to put a bigger costume on
before they shoot more scenes the
cutting-edge concept behind the Marvel
Universe is this massive organism of
shifting parts and new ideas how do we
do this as a team Seraphin is
responsible for all of these amazing
actors and extras that we brought into
this I think after the first Avengers
people realized that this was not just
an ordinary comic-book movie that there
was really a lot of thought in a lot of
a lot of passion that's going into each
and every one of these films I can tell
you that each and every one of us is so
grateful our lives are monumentally
changed by our involvement in this world
to have taken such an instrumental role
in what Marvel has done in the past ten
years it's just so incredibly meaningful
to us that's not the end of it either
there are also people showing up in
other places that they didn't go during
infinity war while they were also
filming Avengers endgame because they
filmed infinity war an end game
back-to-back because they filmed the
movies out of order sometimes the actors
wouldn't know if they were filming
scenes that would be an Avengers end
game or if the scenes were going to be
an Avengers infinity war that's why most
of them did not know the plot of the
movie but you look at Iron Man here he
is doing an interview inside sharees lab
in Wakanda and he was nowhere near
Wakanda during Avengers infinity war but
number five the writers revealed that
the movie will be the biggest most epic
thing that Marvel has ever done the most
amount of movie that you could put in a
movie they're talking about emotional
payoffs the biggest ending that they
could possibly have that they probably
won't be able to top to the end of the
next saga of films they also confirmed
that the ending will completely change
the foundation of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe most of us think that this
means leaving plausible room for how
x-men fantastic for Deadpool based
characters can exist alongside the
original MCU characters without
necessarily putting those characters on
screen for Kevin Feige confirmed that
Avengers endgame focuses on the stories
of the six original Avengers characters
no big surprise there
here's his quote people would point out
the cap wasn't an infinity war a whole
lot an Ironman didn't really speak for
the last half hour because of what was
going on but those characters and all of
the original six are very much the focus
of endgame in a very personal and
emotional way so when you're Theory
crafting about what characters are doing
like ant-man Captain Marvel the backup
characters war machine they're probably
gonna do important things but all the
biggest stuff will be on the six
original Avengers shoulders as it should
be what a coincidence that there are six
Infinity stones and there are six
original Avengers remember the original
guardians of the galaxy movie when the
collector is explaining the
d stones to star-lord in the Guardians
once for a moment that group was able to
share the energy amongst themselves but
even they would be destroyed by it there
are a lot of people that are wondering
if they're gonna try and pay that off
with a moment with these original six
Avengers the quantum suits would be a
way to explain how they could harness
the power of Infinity stones without
being destroyed especially people like
Black Widow and Hawkeye that don't have
powers 3 Kevin Feige confirmed that a
ventures endgame is the end of what
they're calling internally the infinity
saga of movies so everything between the
first Iron Man film in Avengers endgame
is the infinity of saga it makes sense
because they were seeding Thanos that
whole time with the Infinity Gauntlet so
Marvel phase 4 will be the beginning of
the next saga of films that will cross
multiple Avengers films obviously they
didn't give away spoilers about what
that saga is going to be they may tease
it a little bit when they do their big
phase 4 movie announcement but they
didn't start talking about the Infinity
Gauntlet till well after the first
Avengers movie came out that was four or
four years after the first Iron Man came
out so it took them a long time to say
oh by the way we're building towards
Thanos in the Infinity Gauntlet so they
might do the same thing with the next
big saga even though they changed a lot
of things about the comics those big
sagas that they do the cross multiple
Avengers films are rooted in core
comic-book stories so when you're
thinking about the biggest possible
things they could do we're talking
Secret Invasion Secret Wars annihilation
maybe original sin war of realms the
biggest most epic things that you could
possibly think of but also remember that
because they'll have all those Fox
Fantastic Four x-men characters make
sure to think about storylines that
include those characters in the comics
we'll be talking about that all summer
long because spider-man far from home is
the first Marvel phase for film - the
writers explain what's going on with the
characters when the movie picks up they
say the Thor is not blaming anyone but
himself talking about should have gone
for the head he does have a lot of guilt
over that moment even though this is
dark cloud over the first act of the
film it's not completely humorless black
widow has no more shits to give she's
just pissed off for a lot of the film so
she's gonna be super hardcore Captain
America is heartbroken but as you can
see during the trailer and based on what
Chris Evans has said that he's sort of
doing
some Greek counseling there were also a
couple of details that confirm my
suspicions about the Stan Lee cameo and
for those of you that weren't sure Stan
Lee does have a cameo during the film he
already shot the next couple of cameos
before he passed away
interestingly enough they did say that
originally they thought about having the
snap take place during Avengers endgame
which probably would have been terrible
but they said that they tested it
audiences hated the end of infinity war
but understood that it had to end that
way so they were satisfied but they
hated that they were satisfied with the
ending even funnier spider-man's death
scene where he turns to dust was one of
the first things that they ever shot for
either of these movies remember when
they released that teaser trailer a
couple years ago saying hey day 1 of
infinity war were filming right now on
this green screen now we know within a
day of this they were filming
spider-man's death scene which i think
is just hilarious that they would start
off with a moment like that because it
was so powerful at the end of the film
number 1 Kevin Feige revealed that there
will be a big Marvel phase 4 movie slate
announcement after avengers endgame it
might also not be till after spider-man
far from home despite the fact that that
is a Marvel phase 4 film but even though
avengers endgame still has about five
weeks to go in post-production before
they release the film and the Fox Disney
deal closes right now Kevin Feige was
not allowed to talk to the Russos about
Fox characters during the making of
avengers endgame or infinity war in the
Russos were not allowed to put bucks
characters in Avengers endgame before
the Fox Disney deal completed in this
late in the game with the movie getting
ready to come out it would take way
longer than they have to magically add
visual effects for Galactus or a bunch
of x-men characters into even the
smallest of post-credit scenes so there
any references to mutants or Fantastic
Four deadpool adjacent things just
expect them to be verbal references
text-based or visual metaphors that are
open to interpretation like oh well this
could be a way to explain how mutants
can exist in the MCU
so just couch your expectations when it
comes to avengers endgame post-credit
scenes I think they're leaning a little
bit more on the stuff that they already
had the rights to so maybe some eternal
stuff maybe some multiverse stuff
something teasing their next big threat
if there's any of that stuff that you
guys want me to make a video about just
let me know in the comments below or if
you have big questions congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video truth patel please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here to learn all
about fan oohs during avengers endgame
and click here to re-watch the Avengers
endgame trailer a billion more times
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you